salut comment tu verras ils pas leurs
noms mais il va pas tarder la téléphonie
ça va oui ça fait dix mois alors que tu
fais ben je refais l'hôtel du nord tels
qu'ils étaient autrefois avant ouais je
le réhabilite gelé refait tel qu'il
était avant on a fait des arrêts sur
image
et puis on s'est inspiré du film pour
toute la déco d'accord alors là c'est
tout le bistrot et puis derrière ben je
vais faire un bistrot un café la caf et
cafés et restos ici on a refait tous les
faux bois les les vieux miroirs des
vieilles mosaïque un tas il va y avoir
la moquette fait partie des images du
film c'est ça on a fait des arrêts sur
image est aussi inspiré complètement du
film mais d'après la déco qui avait fait
trôner en c'est drôle du nord ouais mais
c'est quoi depuis le temps ici ben là
ici c'était c'était rien du tout c'était
une loge de concierge que j'ai récupéré
il y avait le café qui existaient mais
qui était complètement foutue qui allait
être démoli les riverains se sont battus
et ont gagné justement pour que la
façade soit classée et et puis là j'en
ai fait une salle de resto et au-dessus
l'auteur l'hôtel c'est devenu des
apparts à mort ouais cher oui peut-être
mais tu vas faire quoi comme comme si le
restaurant de cuisine française
traditionnelle en plat du jour
l'aviez boulila vieille bouffe française
voilà le chanteur oui il va y avoir des
animations avec des chanteuses et des
chanteurs le personnel chante aussi et
tout le répertoire des années 30-40 le
répertoire de damiatte fréhel de piaf et
10 mois tout a été ouvert le but c'était
quoi en 65 35 oui si jal mars est en moi
je me souviens savez c'est pas y aller
j'avais 16 ans mois ouais et dis moi que
tu as fait rare depuis belge en effet 20
j'ai fait vingt discothèque avant et là
c'est un peu ma retraite va ouais ça
fait quoi genre de spectacle ben j'ai
fait le nashville en 76 sous la halle un
tiens j'ai fait le xénon à new york
j'ai fait le studio à auchan elysées je
me souviens et puis et puis j'en ai fait
d'autres enfin incliné qui était moins
connu
j'ai fait aussi un café concert qui
s'appelait la goulue rue des petits
champs qui était simple avis ça a été
beaucoup de bas quelques voiles gens
sympas ah ouais baptisé l'hôtel du genre
en plus tu te branche chèques et
touristes japonais déjà tition de
remplir c'est vrai il n'arrête pas de
prendre des photos la face à céret c'est
un monument historique d'art achetées la
ba oui je pense c'est mythique un ouais
sauf quand ça ouvre pour le réveillon du
jour de l'an précédent pas longtemps
dans très peu de temps
voilà comment ça va vous êtes surpris de
mon choix ouvre un c'est bénéfique à la
balle et c'est beau c'est somptueux non
ça va vu ce qu'il fait là il a fait
chaud james un job
un lyonnais sont là dès le premier effet
tourné à bon ouais non non non non elle
nous on n'a rien qu'elle peut le prendre
dans les bras ils avaient la même gueule
je fus un chapeau et me lagarde est un
fait commun tant que tu le connais assaf
et chose plus nerveux ne le dira pas que
le bus était en 65 ch à 30 ans tu m'as
donc c'était avant ah bon c'est encore
avant maintenant se connaissaient
on avait un petit vent des défauts sujet
du beh dont on taira le nom
tu vois mais bon c'était une époque où
james était très intéressé par les
courses à lille était toujours fourré à
auteuil ou à longchamp et puis c'était
un flambeur il avait la même gueule et
benoît chabod n'était pas d assortir
était toujours un petit costard voilà
donc on est potes depuis très longtemps
mais ce que géniale ici c'est guy m'a
expliqué jane c'est qu'il a arrêté le
film pour retrouver exactement les
arrêts c'est extraordinaire les décors
de trauner ça c'est génial là j'ai pas
fini c'est la bière pas pour le moment
si les repas écoute moi je viens si elle
est si elle est fraîche et bien préférer
les barreaux
comment tu vas toi tu étais à tahiti
c'est samedi ouais bah t'as l'air en
forme
je suis prêt je sors du montage donc je
suis abrutis manon des ventes à l'air
frais quand même au rating tu bois puis
tu fumes plus là non
depuis quand même temps j'y vois plus le
métier 1 à 3 degrés ça ouais ouais le
puits contient depuis trois ans ça va
faire 4 en faire quatre ans que je ne
touche que j'étais quand on est d'accord
des comics et moi répéter c'est quand tu
as fait ton comptage
ah qu'est ce que tu as eu l'arrêt direct
triple pontage triple avantage là donc
tu pouvais plus de toute façon non
gergorin quadruples maintenant c'est
vrai bon c'est vrai c'est sûr c'est sûr
que si tu veux c'est tu es obligée là le
coup de semonce est telle que tu t'es
pas arrêté les clopes et comme tout tu
me demandes tout je te dit tout les
visites en matière très bonne mine tel
un frêle à tana je suis plus grâce à
s'en remettre à la peau fraîche
j'ai pris 15 kilos de riz qu est ce qu
il voit la regarde l'autre taré pays
klopp abattant moi j'ai pas encore une
triple pontage salah je peux en voir
continuer voilà on peut y aller
ces séquences ccre sept tombes tu ton
âge à la télé je m'en fous certains
seront dix ont été balancés vu ça c'est
chiant pour marquer ils ont déboulé ils
vivent pas sans les balances c'est quand
même s'il ya pas de balancier pas de
poulet il n'y a pas d'affaires je suis
large connaît bien tout ça c'est que ça
fait ça fait 20 ans et moi tu sais ça
ouais ça je sais je sais j'ai calculé
que c'était 1,75 que j'avais démarré que
tu te rends compte 1
ça fait 20 ans de visibilité ouais ça
fait combien les moulins pour lui faire
une quarantaine ouais y'a pas fait
beaucoup si le comparer à mon camarade
navarro navarro ouais qu'il y en a fait
une cinquantaine dans 56 ans est en
voiture
moi j'en ai fait combien de parents à
l'agent fait pas
pour faire un bon jeu tu peux te
permettre quoi vis-à-vis de fonds
accordés permettent je vous ai vu mon
portefeuille mais vis-à-vis des vins
n'ont baissé de le le rythme jusqu'à
présent c'était je règne en enfer 13 en
trois ans mais comme c'est moi qui les
écrit et que je les réalise c'est pas
plus avancé enfin un peu plus maintenant
parce que je vais arrêter de les
réaliser mais chamfort à 2,3 quoi voilà
tu as un sens plus conditionnée en
entrevue t'avais dit aux stups après
deux ans ils ont forcément une semaine
n'aura peut être plus les faits c'est
une affaire qui opérait ya prescription
j'ai payé à les condamner à 30 mille
balles là dessus ouais ouais j'ai été
poursuivi par qui laisse ben oui c'est
vrai dire ah ouais alors que c'est vrai
qu'ils ont cru à à séville s'applique à
ces ferries moi j'ai dit une fois the
deep et de superviser ces content
d'avoir fait moules à mélanger sec
non moi je suis aux seuils ardisson
si changer moi je te vois tu rends
compte dans un temps mais la restaurant
qui s'appelle cj willy lam il est
sérieux comme apens il bouffe toujours
seul dans son coin rapide haute à je
prends des notes pendant les attaques il
ya il est vachement sérieux une bonjour
en voir dans son coin
c'est vrai que tu fais toi tu peux plus
rien faire alors tu ne fumes plus tu
bois pu reste encore plein de choses
traînent dans les boîtes de toussaint a
été vidée sérieux comme un pape lors il
est détesté tout ce que j'avais mais les
prix les champs dit non non non non non
mais ça me scie les bois les boîtes de
peine
ça ça me fait marrer lesquels on emballe
queen's puis lui quand il avait son
cirque
c'était sympa il y avait des mecs en
porte jarretelles attendant je sais pas
mais bon geek du web et stocke ses
dessins pas aller là-bas mais je suis
content mon chien ouais
comment il s'appelle baba bâ sur cabaye
gens très bien mme obama bien tu écoutes
le colis de berne n'est pas ton père mon
bâton ici parce qu'il dit il est aveugle
non mon bébé pour ils veulent qu il a 15
ans il revient du n'est pas ça ce n'est
pas laid c'est un chèque j'ai ramené de
la banque 80 et donc qu'il va sur ses 15
ans tu vois ça nous fait sens
10 x 7 cents 6 cents à 35 105 ans
commence à faire non non non mais il est
bien c'est quelqu'un qui mise et yves
durand l'euthanasie je limite les
malades à temps pourquoi tant qu il est
bien il voit pas bon il entend pas mais
je dis ah bon et bien partout il me faut
encore le plan sera rude à chier dans
l'ascenseur et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu